this is my main cabinet which I built
some years ago it now lives permanently
here at the HACC space we don't act up
money everything is free so in order to
insert coins I just provide a button you
can have as many credits as you like
when people see it for the first time
there they're always looking for the
game that they played when they were
kids it's a custom carpentry cabinet
that was built around a 17 inch monitor
at the time the reason why it has the
all of the shape that it has so that I
could play the game defender in as
realistic a manner as possible inside we
have an old the Pentium 4 it just
happens to be the most recent free PC I
got hold of name is an acronym for
multiple arcade machine emulator just
emulate different arcade machine
hardware there were just computers
there's quite a lot of different popular
processors z80 6868 thousands it's
basically just a PC and the only fancy
stuff is the controls hmm well the
joysticks and
buttons are just micro switches all of
the micro switches come out and come
into a keyboard matrix whilst this one
is based on keyboard make tricks
breakout that I managed to get as part
of my job previous incarnations have had
I've just ripped out the keyboard matrix
from a keyboard but when you press a
button on a keyboard there's a
two-dimensional matrix of contacts you
join up a row in a column that sends a
signal to a small very small pic
programmable interrupt controller a pic
which that interprets that and send out
a keyboard scan code to the PC you get a
means of input in 150 different buttons
or
like that in practice you can't really
use all of those button presses because
keyboard controllers tend to think that
if you press more than four buttons at
once that the cat sat on the keyboard or
something like that and it disables
those keys the various key presses that
result from joystick movements coming to
what it what is broken out as a keyboard
matrix here and just goes down into the
PC I've also got an external keyboard
for convenient typing of of commands and
what-have-you these joysticks are either
eight-way or four-way if you are playing
a maze type game say pac-man you
definitely don't want diagonals because
they register say up and left at the
same time and it's entirely up to the
game whether you're going to go left or
up when you get to a junction these
joysticks have a built-in template it's
selectable from above which is one of
the reasons why I spent the massive 50
pounds on these choices which limits the
angles of which the joystick can go it
basically cuts out the corners so you
can only go up down left or right and
that's selected by lifting the joystick
and giving it a twist currently runs a
version of Ubuntu a very lightweight up
onto Cole exam on - with spelt with an X
Linux is free you're free to make it do
just what you want so that you retain
control of your computing experience
it's not the most recent abun to release
each upgrade require a bit more
computing power so I'm going for the low
end up onto light weight distribution
and every time I change it there are
things to fix so I'm sticking with what
I've got right now okay right so this
comes out yes please excuse the mess
it's basically running the xfce desktop
the cholesterol-free computing
environment I'm using a front-end called
work aid which is basically a Python
front-end that will give us a nice
keyboard based user interface through
which we can select which game we want
to play launch the game and it starts
the name application for us hiding all
the computer
business we're free to select from the
different games that happen to have the
cabinet design is based on the genuine
defender arcade machine developed by
Williams in 1980 in fact the coach bonus
was written over a weekend in time for a
trade play and it turned out to be one
of the most popular games of the early
1980s defender is a strange game in that
it has an up-and-down joystick and seven
additional buttons it does mean that I
use both player one and player two
controls and so although I'm not playing
very well at the moment because I
multitask
my intention is to become as good as the
heroes I had when I was a teenager who
would play defender all day in the
arcade for just anything I only really
work with stuff but I get the knocking
stuff that would otherwise be thrown
away this is an old monitor from a
railway destination indicator I get to
pick up things like this due to my job
when we do refurbishments of railway
stations it will have displayed
departures how late your train is that
sort of thing there's a certain amount
of screen burn which odd to see right
now but there's it yet